how can a traditional Alpha Man or even
just a normal man a guy like you and me
balance living their life and dealing
with modern women well guys like you and
me understand the way things work my
friend we've unplugged from The Matrix
for guys like you and me it's okay well
let's not invite chaos into her life
stay away from women with loads of red
flag a lot of the times like I'll give a
guy my book and they get mad it's like
well there's no women if I have to vet
them all with these 20 here that I'm
never going to get a girl Rich okay well
that's the reality of society today the
reason why I give you these tools is so
that you can see them for what they are
understand them and then you know adapt
accordingly but what they don't seem to
understand is well if that's all that
you see then that's all that you are
worth do more work on yourself become
more competent you know learn more about
game learn more about you know whatever
is it you got to sort of fix your life
maybe you're boring as [__] I don't know
but if all you see is 20 red flags and
every single woman that you talk to
there's something wrong with you I'm in
an LTR my gal is great there's lots of
women out there that don't have red
flags do the work on yourself and they
will become available to you